she's not a bird or a plane and she's
definitely not Superman Melissa Benoist
a CW Supergirl but how does she get
ready for the part let's take a look at
how this self-proclaimed musical theater
nerd got into fighting condition to play
the high-flying
hard punching Supergirl you don't just
get handed a role like Supergirl Melissa
Benoist had to go through a rigorous
audition process before she got anywhere
close to landing the role the weight was
made even more excruciating because
according to Benoist she was among the
first actors to audition for the parts
the first audition was in October 2014
and it was just the start of what would
become a months long process she told
Entertainment Weekly that she didn't
learn she landed the part until February
2015 in the interim she said I went
through multiple screen tests multiple
auditions or the producing team there
was a lot during that extensive audition
process variety reported that Benoist
found a champion in producer Greg
Berlanti Benoist said Greg championed me
the whole time and was in my corner even
when I didn't think the part was mine he
was always rooting for me that support
goes a long way especially when I'm
fighting for something I want so badly
his belief in me really touched me
Villante echoed the sentiment praising
the Supergirl star by saying if we had
not found her I would have said I don't
want to make this the first episode
aired almost a year after the first
audition on October 26th 2015
she's inhabited the roles ever since
serving as an inspiration for fans
around the world didnäôt are there like
a million little girls that dress up as
Supergirl now as a result of the show
every Halloween there are quite a bit of
Supergirl one thing that all superheroes
have in common are incredible abs I'm a
noise Supergirl is no exception
she said in interviews that to prepare
for the role of Kara zor-el she focused
on both strength training and core work
getting toned with a combination of
Pilates boxing and plyometrics if you've
never had a reason to get into superhero
shape you might be wondering what
plyometrics are plyometrics involve
exerting your body to his maximum
ability for a short period of time
for example by jumping to improve
strength speed and power as Benoist
found out pilo routines are far from
easy work did I did quite a bit of
training we did this stuff called
plyometrics which is a jump training and
all of it was really
hard just hard things all that focus on
the core isn't just for the sake of
looking good it also comes in handy when
you're doing flying stunts to do the
flying stunts you know I'm up in a wire
and you have to hold your entire body
weight so there's a lot of training
involved Melissa Benoist wasn't the only
cast member who had to upper workout
intensity to give the action sequences
he effort they deserved
Kyle early who plays Cara's adoptive
sister Alex said that the actors work
really hard with the stunt coordinators
to get the fight scenes just right and
those action-packed days are full of
workouts in their own right
she told CBS watch Magazine when we do
fight scenes we're working out for six
hours just doing the same thing we are
burnt for the next few days I think
that's where I really get my caloric
burn count even when they aren't
shooting liam Benoist try to use their
periods of waiting around that happened
on the set of a TV show
to stay in shape she said Melissa and I
try to do as much as we possibly can in
my trailer
I've got resistance bands and medicine
balls and things like that I tried to do
it in between but we have very little
downtime the two on-screen sisters also
have a shared interest in Pilates which
Lise say she fits into a schedule when
she can as you thought TV sets roar
hanging out in trailers enjoying craft
services another crucial element of
being a superhero is being able to
convincingly kick some villanous but
this didn't come naturally to Benoist
who confess to the Chicago Tribune
I had never punched anyone I may be
slapped my sisters when I was a kid but
I am NOT an aggressive violent person
and I had no idea how to throw a punch
in order to help herself find her in a
fighter but noise took a boxing she told
in style I definitely had to learn
technique like how to actually punch
someone and not hurt yourself more than
you're hurting the person you're
punching
fortunately for Benoist she had access
to excellent shooters in addition to the
stunt team a former karate and
kickboxing mo Champion Lexi Alexander
directed an episode in the first season
her directing stim was short but
Alexander told den of geek that she
pushed her star to the limit saying this
was a brand new thing for everybody
involved and everybody was excited that
a real fighter was getting Melissa
Benoist to the next level of fight
choreography in fact the change of
Benoist technique was so dramatic the
alexander said
series stuntin changement ice his
fighting style going forward to
incorporate her expert tips so walpa
noise might so heart still be more lover
than a fighter we still wouldn't want to
challenge her to throw down at this
point I actually kind of love it believe
it or not it really is Benoist doing
some of those hair-raising stunts on the
show the actress told variety that she
likes to get involved with the action
when she can saying I have been doing a
lot of stunts and I want to keep doing
them super girls fight moves a boxing
she's really heavy-handed there's some
flying that involves kicking and
punching mid-flight that's kind of
Awesome however not everyone was
thrilled with Benoist hand on approach
to fights her mom Julie told her that
she found it difficult to watch her
daughter's fight scenes especially
against men but Julie Benoist needn't
have worried Melissa knows her limits
and she's also heaped praise on a stunt
doubles in 2015 she spoke to InStyle on
the subject of stunts saying I think
they're so fun there are some that I
just can't I really could get injured
[Music]
Glee was not Benoist first experience
with musical theater she say she's been
practicing the craft since she was four
years old attending classes and tap
ballet and jazz dance but she wasn't
always a perfect student especially in
ballet all the years I took ballet class
I was the one kid in class that the
teacher was always like oh yeah her turn
out and she is not standing up straight
she did Benson with another form of
Dance
when she showed off in a video for
glamour I have a secret superpower that
I can tap down
that dance training came in handy on the
set of Supergirl and not just for
Benoist part in the musical crossover
episode of the flash I have to say I'm
not impressed
by your more famous cousin thank you no
one ever says that her noise said to her
dance backgrounds helps up with the
wirework and even the fight sequences
she told the Chicago Tribune the
wirework and flying even the
choreography kind of came like it would
if I were learning a dance routine it's
also a handy skill that keeps her on the
crew entertained between takes Melissa
Benoist favorite thing about her
superhero role is exactly what you'd
expect the chance to fly
seems like flying wouldn't be so great
when you're pretending to play I mean
it's hard work I'm essentially like
attached to a fork in the air the spy
tells some skilled animators make it
look on-screen flying isn't easy
especially when you have to act like
it's all effortless to you but noise
Todd variety just how hard it was and
how she prepared saying the while work
for training is mostly core work it's
mostly AB centric the whole area of the
body that nobody wants to work out you
have to get strong you have to carry
your whole body weight when you're up in
the air however it's all worth all the
working out to make the process run
smoothly she told people the wire work
is really difficult but so fun and when
you get it right watching the result is
exhilarating it's a really really cool
feeling to know what it felt like the
energy I had to exert to create those
flying scenes and then the way it looks
is really rewarding but noise got some
help affecting a flying technique when
Jimmy Kimmel last saw she figured out
supergirls flying style she had a
surprising answer in store almost
superhero physicality school that you go
to that team will teach you like how to
walk like a superhero and that's how to
look fly in spandex all that working out
and on set action builds up an appetite
but as a female superhero is expected to
squeeze into a tight superhero suit
every day and have the muscles to beat
the bad guys without actually looking or
that bogged up but noise can't exactly
go to town and craft services
fortunately she's pretty into fruits and
vegetables anyway she gushed a glamour I
love supermarkets I love grocery
shopping
I love the produce aisle and
to be super you have to be healthy and I
would probably stock up on all the fruit
however she isn't about to totally
deprived herself of comfort foods in the
same glamour interview she said if I
could supersize any food it would be ice
cream drumstick vanilla caramel they're
so good
in 2016 she told the Chicago Tribune
that she was excited to attend that
year's Chicago Comic Con and
Entertainment Expo aka c2e2 not just the
commune with fellow artists and fans but
because she wanted to check out the
city's restaurants as she explains quote
I've heard the food scene is incredible
and I'm a foodie so I can't wait to go
out and eat when also said that her
partiality to the occasion or junk food
splurge inspired the writers to add the
habit into a character's personality she
said I love junk food
I love donuts and they put that in there
quite a bit you're like donuts doesn't
like donuts I know please it just goes
to show that it's long into a
disciplined of your workouts you don't
have to deprive yourself of every treat
you love one reason Melissa Benoist was
so invested in making sure her character
could be physically impressive on screen
was because she wanted to inspire other
women to feel strong and powerful in
their own lives in an essay for time she
wrote I think the more the show goes on
the more you see this fierceness and
what women are really capable of it puts
Supergirl on this equal playing field
that's so meaningful to me to help
children understand that girls can have
just as much fun as that male
counterparts in the superhero world it's
about confidence and hope and Supergirl
really embodies all of that even though
Benoist also wrote that she grew up in a
quote really strong feminine family
she told the Chicago Tribune I didn't
really believe that I could be that
character or play a superhero it's
something I never thought of myself was
doing but I just knew I had to go for it
because there's so few female
superheroes and just strong females that
fight back and do it with grace and do
it with love he's also said that she
doesn't want the character to be a
female version of male superheroes
saying what I think is cool is to try to
bring a kind of femininity to a strength
I do like the idea of bringing in like a
grace to it and the fluidity and kind of
this femininity to flying it's fun
in other words belissa bone oysters out
here bringing new meaning to super girl
power check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
buy your favorite DC superheroes I come
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]